is there something you found really
impressive about queen's gambit the tv
show you know that's one of the things
that really captivated the public
imagination about chess people don't
play chess or became very curious about
the game about the beauty of the game
the drama of the game all that kind of
stuff is there in terms of accuracy in
terms of the actual games played that
you found
impressive
first of all they did the chess that did
the chess while they did it accurately
and also
they found actual games and positions
that i never never seen before
which really captivated me like i would
i would not follow the um
the story at times i was just trying to
wow where the hell did i find that game
trying to solve the positions
so beth harmon the uh the the main
character
were you impressed by the play she was
doing in in the like was there a
particular style that they developed
consistently but she was just at the end
she was just totally universal
like at the start
she was probably a bit too too
aggressive but no she was absolutely
universal you know wait what were the
what adjective are you using universal
in the sense that she could play in any
any style
oh interesting and and was dominant in
that way so wow they said there's a
development in style too throughout the
show yeah for sure it's really
interesting they did they did that yeah
and uh it actually happened with me a
bit as well like i started out really
aggressive
then i became probably
too technical at some point uh taking a
little bit too few risks and not playing
dynamic enough and then i started to get
a little bit better at dynamics so that
now i'm
i would say definitely the most
universal player in terms of
in terms of style
you